[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député de la
Somme vice-président du groupe
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée
nationale on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par Stéphane Vernet de wouest
France bonjour Stéphane bonjour Arian
Jean-Philippe Tang bonjour bonjour
bonjour on va évidemment commencer par
la crise agricole Jean-Philippe Tanguy
et ces blocages qui se poursuivent un
petit peu partout sur le territoire ces
tracteurs qui convergent vers Paris on
entend certaines phrases prononcées par
les agriculteurs on veut affamer les
Parisiens disent-il est-ce que c'est
acceptable est-ce que vous soutenez ce
mouvement ah bah le il y a deux choses
différentes le mouvement le je le
soutiens évidemment je rappelle même
qu'on l'a annoncé le fait de de venir
aujourd'hui sur la Chaîne Parlementaire
me fait quand même rappeler que le
rassemblement national à la rentrée de
septembre avait mis la taxation du
gazolle Non Routier qui a été la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder un vase très
rempli l'agricole voilà et donc mais la
manière il y a quelques phrases qui
peuvent être effectivement provocatrice
mais c'est à la mesure de la détresse
agricole faut pas non plus se laisser
tromper divertir par des quelques
phrases qui ne sont pas représentatives
de l'écrasante majorité du mouvement moi
je viens de la Somme département
agricole s'il en est tout se passe très
bien c'est très organisé ça large
soutien de la population les paysans se
font entendre sans embêter les gens qui
travaillent et de toute façon la clé de
ce mouvement c'est la converence entre
les gens qui travaent en bloquant les
grands axes ça embête forcément
certaines personnes des gens qui
travaillent et d'autres est-ce que euh
vous dites c'est pas la bonne méthode
bah pour le moment euh la solidarité est
là et je crois que les les les
désagréments qui peuvent survenir ne
sont pas du tout euh ne sont pas du tout
à la mesure de de de ce que vivent les
agriculteurs parce que c'est tous les
gens qui travaillent en France savent
que vivre de son travail c'est désormais
un enjeu de société majeur mais
vous-même la semaine dernière vous avez
appelé publiquement à ce que les
agriculteurs bloquent un certain nombre
de de points névralgique dans le marché
de ringis par exemple donc vous
maintenez cette position mais mes propos
on ét un peu détourné ce que j'avais dit
c'est que justement il ne fallait pas
gêner le travail de 99 % des Français
que le cas échéant mieux valait centrer
des actions sur les points symboliques
j'avais dit symbolique d'ailleurs mais
mais moi je vaux pas être mal compris
les gens aragissent travaillent font
tourner l'économie ce que je voulais
dire c'est que les agriculteurs savent
aussi quels sont les symboles qui
représentent les déséquilibres du marché
les forces notamment la grande
distribution et l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui sont qu' part de
responsabilité importante puisqu'il n'y
a pas d'arbitrage des gouvernements pour
des prix mé on comprend pas est-ce que
vous cautionnez ou pas le blocage de
ringis ou est-ce que vous dites Gérald
armanaana a un raison de tout faire pour
l'empêcher moi je cautionne pas si vous
voulez qu'on empêche des gens de
travailler ou qu'on exerce des violences
mais je n'ai pas du tout l'impression
que ce soit la volonté des agriculteurs
c'était plus de d'envoyer un symbole de
dire ringis représente une part du
déséquilibre dans le partage de de la
valeur ajoutée d'ailleurs Mar dit ringis
c'est l'agriculture française c'est là
où vont les produits français c'est là
où s'écoulent les produits français s'il
y a blocage de ringis s'il y a blocage
de l'écoulement des produits français et
les les les gens iront chercher des
produits ailleurs et ça va nuire à
l'agriculture non mais Marc fen dit
beaucoup de bêtises il était ministre de
l'Agriculture non mais il dit beaucoup
de bêtisse et en particulier le fait de
de faire croire que BCE qu'on fait une
action ragisse on va affamer toute la
France il faut que monsieur F revienne
sur Terre ce serait aussi ça va
pénaliser l'agriculture française oui
mais c'est c'est ce qui veut dire en en
dernier ressort euh monsieur F ministre
de l'agriculture il n'a rien vu venir il
est complètement enfermé dans ses
certitudes il n'a pas vu la crise
montere il y a d'abord eu le
retournement des panneaux dans toutes
les communes rurales de France il n'a
rien voulu venir il y a le rassemblement
national dont votre serviteur qui l'a
prévenu sur le fait que son accord avec
les dirigeants de la FNSEA ne tenait pas
et n'était n'était pas suivi pardon par
la base il n'a pas tenu compte de nos
remarques et maintenant il est débordé
par le mouvement et il nous explique
tout ce qu'il a fait et si formidable
qu'il y a la une des plus grosses
révoltes agricoles que notre pays est
connu donc monsieur devraitû il est
complètement débordé puisqueen fait la
logique de la macronie à savoir ne pas
intervenir ne pas réguler l'économie ne
faire que des demandes le mot de
Monsieur le maire depuis des années à la
grande distribution soit pour aider les
consommateurs avec l'hyperinflation soit
aujourd'hui pour payer correctement les
salariés les agriculteurs pardon pour
leur travail pareil avec l'UST
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui a des
marges de 40 à 50 % sur ces produits
alors que les paysans n'arrivent pas
vivre de leur travail on voit bien que
ce gouvernement est débordé par par
pardon sa propre idéologie à savoir ne
jamais vouloir être l'arbitre dans
l'ordre économique vous pensez que le
mouvement pourrait faire tagehuile
pourrait s'étendre à d'autres secteurs
est-ce qu'on pourrait être dans une
situation type gilet jaune pour vous ou
pas oui mais c'est c'est possible
puisquen fait les les la source de
l'indignation est la même à savoir des
gens qui travaillent dur et qui
n'arrivent pas à vivre de leur travail à
cause de réglementation stupide à cause
de taxation indigente ou à cause
d'injustice dans la répartition de la V
ajoutée donc le BTP pourrait rentrer
dans le mouvement le transport routier
évidemment les pêcheurs qui sont aussi
en état de survie ou plutôt menacés tout
simplement de mort he Jordane bardala
est allé soutenir mardi dernier les
pêcheurs en Bretagne et tous ceux qui
travaillent dans le golf de Gascogne et
ailleurs moi je suis Boulogne sur mer
quand je vois l'état de la pêche par
rapport à ce que j'ai connu quand
j'étais petit ça fait vraiment mal au
cœur vous vous souhaiteriez un mouvement
de cette nature ou vous le redoutez
c'est quelque chose qui vous inquiète ou
vous vous l'appelez de vos vœux moi je
ne je ne redoute pas le fait que des
gens veuillent faire valoir leurs droits
moi c'est ces mouvements pour le moment
ne sont pas violents il représentent un
sentiment de de la population et il est
très bien encadré donc moi je n'ai pas
en tant que responsable politique je
n'ai pas à mettre de lui sur le feu ou à
dire aux gens ce qu'ils ont à faire par
contre moi en tant que député de terrain
je sais que la colère dans le pays elle
est là vous parlez des gilets jaunes les
questions qui avaient été soulevées par
les gilets jaunes savoir une fois de
plus hein ne pas être étouffé par les
dépenses contraintes comme l'ont dit
comme l'a dit Marine Le Pen à la
présidentielle pouvoir vivre de son
travail ne pas être privé de liberté de
circuler de liberté de vivre une vie VI
digne en fait tous ces problématiques
des gilets jaunes n'ont jamais été
vraiment résolu par Emmanuel Macron
elles ont été gravement aggravées si je
puis dire par par la crise de
l'hyperinflation sur mesures le Premier
ministre a pris le temps de de de
préparer un train de mesures qu'il a
présenté vendredi dernier n pas suffit à
apaiser la colère des agriculteurs
qu'est-ce qu'il a raté de votre point de
vue mais il ne veut pas mettre dans le
débat et sur la table la le partage de
la valeur les agriculteurs les paysans
veulent des prix justes ils veulent une
juste rémunération de leur travail
pardon en quoi pas sur la table
Jean-Philippe il a une Galim qui a été
faite de no Galim qui on été faite
depuis qu'emu est au pouvoir qui vise
justement à mieux rémunérer les
agriculteurs pourquoi vous dites qu'il
veut pas mettre déb parce que la loi
égalim en fait visait à faire payer les
consommateur ce qui n'a jamais été dit
au français évidemment ça n'a jamais été
pour contraintre la grande distribution
surt à ce que les agriculteurs ne soi
pas laisés
d'accord ils sont sur les routes madame
ils sont sur les routes ils bloquent les
rond-points et ils sont très en colè et
ils ont raison ces lois n'ont pas
fonctionné ce n'est pas parce que le
gouvernement dit on fait une loi qui a
cet objectif que c'est vrai ces lois
mais là il dit on va on va faire des
contrôles on va faire des sanctionsvers
les entreprises qui qui ne respectent
pas la loi égalime pourquoi vous dites
qu'il met pas le sujet sur la table
parce que d'une part il avoue que les
contrôles n'ont pas été fait auparavant
mais au-delà de ça la loi égalim protège
continue à protéger la grande
distribution et l'industrie
agroalimentaire et vise au dernier
ressort à faire payer les consommateurs
ce n'est pas la logique qu'il faut il ne
veut pas s'attaquer au marges de la
pratique de la grande distribution il ne
veut pas s'attaquer aux marges de
l'industrie agroalimentaire un seul
exemple et vous le savez vous en parlez
régulièrement sur votre antenne jamais
la nourriture en France n'a été aussi
cher avec une surinflation de 20 plus de
20 % en 2 ans et les agriculteurs ne
s'en sortent pas donc on voit bien que
le problème c'est la répartition de la
valeur ajoutée entre le consom
l'agriculteur pardon et le consommateur
et que cette ce système oligarchique
puisque c'est le mot qu'il faut bien lui
donner ne est protégé par la macronie
une fois plus tous les Français l'ont vu
avec l'hyperinflation Monsieur le Maire
n'a jamais voulu mettre les mains dans
le coui et s'attaquer à ce modèle qui ne
fonctionne pas et donc les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui moi supprimer des normes
c'est très bien revoir le le mode de
contrôle très bien mais ce n'est pas les
que vous faites de plus que les lois
égalim et ben il faut que l'État soit
devienne un état arbitre qui fixe des
des prix planchés vous savez et c'est
même pas antilibéral une des règles de
base du libéralisme c'est d'interdire la
vente à perte et ben aujourd'hui en
France les agriculteurs les paysanss les
pêcheurs aussi d'ailleurs sont la seule
profession qui dont on les force à
vendre à perte donc des prix planchés
qui calculent le prix de revien et qui
assure que aucune aucun contrat aucune
négociation ne se fasse en dessous du
prix de revien de fabrication prod la
grand distribution n'ira pas voir
ailleurs mais il faut l'interdire ça
aussi Jord B vous imposez de tel prix
Jordane Bardella a annoncé qu'il fallait
une grande loi de patriotisme économique
effectivement vous avez raison que ce
soit Lecler ou d'autres ont annoncé des
centrales d'achat maintenant européennes
qui contrôneraient les lois françaises
et bien il faut punir et sanctionner les
centrales d'achat la grande distribution
quand elle se comporte ainsi ou annonce
se comporte ASI gouvernement on va
sanctionner les distributeurs qui on va
sanctionner les distributeurs qui ne
respectent pas la loi égalim c'est bien
le message du gouvernement mais madame
c'est pas un message faire respecter la
loi c'est le rôle de l'exécutif bien
nommé exécuter la loi voilà bon le fait
qu'ils ai annoncé en fait qu'au bout de
tant d'années les contrôles n'était pas
fait ou les sanctions n'étaient pas
appliquées prouve ce que je vous dis il
n'y a pas de vol soit l'état qui impose
les prix pour vous c'est pas imposer les
prix et ça c'est du soviétisme c'est de
dire c'est de dire que les prix ne
doivent pas être en dessous du coup de
revien c'est un état arbitre il s'agit
pas de fixer administrativement les prix
il s'agit que quand la grande
distribution et l'agroalimentaire
abusent de leur position dominante parce
qu'en fait il faut que les gens qui nous
regardent comprennent on parle de gens
qui ont des position dominante sur le
marché par rapport aux agriculteurs ils
sont trop forts par rapport aux
agriculteurs donc il faut que l'État
soit un arbitre dites-moi là vous avez
une approche très macroéconomique
politique un peu d' haut vous êtes vous
êtes député de la 4e circonscription de
la somme c'est une terre très rural
est-ce que vous allez voir les paysans
de votre circonscription et qu'est-ce
qu' vous demande est-ce qu'il vous
tiennent le même discours quelles sont
quelles sont les demandes est-ce que
vous allez les voir déjà ah oui B je
vois qu'est-ce qu'il vous demande
précisément aujourd'hui alor dans un
premier temps il demandit surtout qu'on
vote pas donc cette hausse de taxes du
gazol non routier c'est pour ça que j'ai
alerté non parce que moi je tiens aussi
à le dire aler gouverement gouvernement
s'est engagé là-dessus il a il y a
d'autres points non mais très bien mais
il faut quand même comprendre aussi la
logique vous me demandez ce que je suis
en contact avec les agriculteurs on a un
ministre de l'Agriculture moi et le
groupe rassemblement national Marine Le
Pen m'avait donné mandat pour négocier
ce point avec le gouvernement nous les
avons alerté donc ils ne nous ont pas
écouté on nous dit toujours oui vous
mettez de l'uile sur le feu pas du tout
on a essayé d'éviter ce conflit dans un
premier temps ensuite il y a le contrôle
le contrôle des normes mais la
surtransposition évidemment des normes
européennes ça il faut faire un grand
ménage dans les normes mais la question
centrale on le voit sur les barrages
c'est pour ça que vous en parle tout à
l'heure c'est la question des prix les
paysans ne veulent plus être dépendants
d'un système de subvention qui en fait
est poure pour eux des menottes puisque
par que ces subventions sont toujours
liées à imposer des comportements à
imposer des pratiques je vais vous
donner un exemple concret d'un
agriculteur qui m'a si dans ma
circonscription on lui retire toutes ses
a PAC parce qu'il ne veut pas vendre son
exploitation il veut continuer à
travailler et donc on on a encore le
droit dans notre pays de vouloir
travailler si on a envie de travailler
et ben le les règles de la PAC
conditionnent le fait que vous êtes aidé
si vous laissez votre exploitation parce
qu'on estime que vous avez atteint
certain âge et ben j'estime que ce genre
de pratique abusive l'État n'a pas à
dire aux gens s'ils ont droit de
travailler
justement faites partie vous faites
partie des des des gens qui demandent
une refondte de la la politique agricole
commune absolument Mo et pareil moi je
Clure de revenir aux sources et aux
causes la PAC a servi à pour que
l'Europe soit autonome de manière
alimentairement pardon le les paysans
ont réussi cet objectif l'Europe était
devenue autonome du point de vue
alimentaire on était souverain pour
notre alimentation et pour notre
agriculture depuis c'est devenu un outil
pour réparer les dégâts de la
mondialisation du libre échange sauvage
et les prix ne sont plus garantis donc
il faut en fait changer de logique il
faut que les rémunér les agriculteurs
vivent de leur travail et que la PAC
Vienne dans un soutien d'investissement
pour la recherche pour la robotisation
bref pour accompagner l'amélioration
quotidienne de l'agriculture mais que ce
ne soit plus un mode de survie pour les
agricultteurs al ça c'est un message qui
passe au sein du du parti comment
comment se fait-il que les les députés
européens rassemblement national par
exemple est vooté pour les les plans
stratégiques nationaux de la PAC qui
sont en vigueur ou par exemple qui a
voté contre le plafonnement des aides à
60000 € par par an à Strasbourg et à
Bruxelles parce que la pack avait fait
un mouvement la dernière pâack avait
fait un mouvement très important dans le
sens de ce que proposait la rassemblé
nationale c'était la renationalisation
c'est-à-dire que Bruxelles a rendu rendu
un certain nombre d'arbitrage mais nous
on n'est pas pour la politique du pire
donc même quand on n'est pas d'accord
avec l'essentiel on est dans
l'opposition à la Commission européenne
à Madame Van deryen qui est soutenu par
exemple par les républicains en France
on va quand même parfois dans le bon
sens voilà c'est pas la politique du
pire mais évidemment ce n'est pas la
politique qu'on appliquerait si on avait
les leviers au Parlement européen à la
Commission européenne et si nous étions
mais sauf que vous l'avez voté
maintenant qu'elle est vootter qu'elle
s'applique sur plusieurs années vous
dites il faut la revoir bah par c'est
pas contradictoire madame on peut
considérer que des choses vont dans le
bon sens mais qu'elles ne sont pas
parfaites à l'inversement excusez-moi
quand on ne la voteit pas parce que je
me souviens des moments où on ne la
votait pas on nous disait oui vous êtes
contre les aides aux agriculteurs donc
de toute façon être dans l'opposition
sur des montants aussi importants des
programmes aussi importants
non nos positions es sont claires nous
voulons un système d'aide
d'accompagnement mais cette a
accompagnement do venir en support des
agriculteurs ça ne doit pas être si vous
voulez la condition cinequanone de leur
survie il faut qu'il vivent de leur
travail quelle est votre position sur
les accords de libre échange on a
beaucoup parlé deaccord de libre échange
qui a été conclu avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande comment est-ce que vous
vous positionnez par rapport à d'autres
accords de libre échange par exemple
l'accord avec le mercosour qui est
encore en débat quelle est la position
du rassembl national on a pour le coup
un vote constant sur les traités de
libre échange nous sommes contre les
trait libre alors vous euréputés se sont
cont tout trait de libre échange pas
contre tout mais tous ceux qu'ganis
l'Union européenne mercour c'est c'est
un despire ils se sont vos députés se
sont abstenus en fait donc c'est pas une
position contre ça m'étonne ça m'étonne
moi je pense qu'on voté qu'on a voté
contre parce que le le le le en tout cas
par exemple la la la motion qui a été
présentée au Parlement français pour s'y
opposer he tout le groupe a voté pour
s'opposer au mercosour donc nous nous
sommesus Emmanuel Macron aussi va il a
ché il a changé d'avis régulièrement
monsieur Macron avant il trouvait ça
formidable c'est général monsieur Macron
change d'avis avant les élections en
période électorale pour dire qu'il va
faire pression et une fois l'élection
passé il signe le soutien c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec le CTA je vous rappelle
que le Parlement français n toujours pas
voté pour traiter avec le Canada si a
les élections eurénes je je note on va
voir mais je note que Monsieur Macron a
changé d'avis sur le Mercosur alors
qu'il y a les élections européenne le 9
juin et que comme la liste de Jordan
Bardella est à plus de 30 % et celle de
sa majorité à moins de 20 % il Essie de
faire croire il est devenu
protectionniste pense que c'est pour ça
bien sûr c'est pour ça monsieur Macron
trités de libre échange est-ce qu'il
faut mettre fin à tous les traités de
libre éch faut mettre faire un moratoire
sur l'ensemble des traités de libre
échange pour sortir l'agriculture du
march des règles de la mondialisation
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'exception
agriculturelle c'est un concept fondé
parallèle à l'exception culturelle
française que les Français connaissent
bien on avait
sorti le monde de la culture notamment
le cinéma des règles de la
mondialisation pour protéger le modèle
français et bien l'alimentation est très
ité ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir des
blocages des exportations françaises
vous avez par exemple vous des députés
en Gironde vous dites quoi au
viticulteurs de Gironde on exporte plus
le vin non je leur dis qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin des traités de libre échange pour
exporter les vins les vins de Gironde
sont tellement réputés ils ont tellement
de de réputation d'images de marque
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de traiter libre
échange pour être échangé ils sont
d'ailleurs échangés depuis le Moyen-âge
tout comme ch quand même des
viticulteurs en Gironde qui ont quelques
souci hein malgré la qualité de leur vin
ils ont des soucis donc c'est pas li au
C libre échange puisqu'ils existent il y
a il y a toujours des problèmes
parce que mondialement c'est parce que
au niveau mondial la tendance notamment
en France vous le savez est de consommer
moins de 20 donc il faut pas tout
mélanger est-ce qu'on a besoin des TR ça
va être encore pire si du coup il y a
moins d'exportation mais il y a pas
forcément moins d'exportation ça ce sont
des raisonnements du gouvernement qui
n'ont pas de sens économiquement un
traité de libre échange vous devez
mettre vos atouts et là où vous êtes
moins fort nous sommes très forts sur
les produits de qualité français et
quand monsieur Trump nous menace par
exemple de ne plus exporter nos
champagne excusez-moi il y a pas
champagne pour satisfaire la demande
mondiale pareil pour le cognac pareil
pour les les grands vins donc il faut
arrêter de faire peur aux gens pour rien
les traités de libre échange et on le
voit n'ont pas fonctionné la balance
commerciale française je vous rappelle
est à Mo- 160 milliards hein avant ces
trité de libre échange la balance
française était positive donc le
commerce la façon dont le commerce a été
organisé ne fonctionne pas parce qu'il
repose sur ce qu'on appelle la la
spécialisation international c'était les
les règles de Ricardo et en fait on n
pas défendu les atouts français donc
au-delà de les traité de libre
libreéchange sont très mal nommés il
s'agit en fait de traiter de de
mondialisation sauvage où on met en
concurrence des pays qui n'ont pas nos
normes qui n'ont pas nos pratiques
sociales qui ne respectent pas les
normes environnementales et on met nos
paysans qui respectent tout cela et qui
font un travail remarquable en face
d'eux sans les protéger le Japon la
Suisse les États-Unis protègent leur
marché et aujourd'hui des pays des
puissances agricoles vous le savez comme
le Brésil en fait organise leur
production en sachant que l'Europe se
désarme voilà mais la concurrence elle
est aussi beaucoup européenne absolument
vous avez raison vous avez raisoni il y
a pas besoin de traité de librechange
vous avez raison c'est un sujet
différent au sein du marché commun la
concurrence aujourd'hui n'est pas loyale
et la Commission européenne plutôt que
de venir mesurer la taille des patates
devrait mieux faire appliquer des règles
je rappelle que le rôle de la Commission
européenne c'est d'être garante des
traités et aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de nos partenaires ne respectent pas les
règles où la France applique trop de
règles donc il faut d'un côté que la
France ne surtranspose plus des règles
et défende une agriculture et qui ne
soit pas seul seulement une agriculture
très haute de gamme mais qui soit aussi
une agriculture qui permet de nourrir
euh les familles modestes et populaires
et que d'un côté nos partenaires
appliquent les règles je rappelle que la
France a un levier de pression c'est ce
que vous savez le général de Gaulle
avait pratiqué la politique de la chaise
vide pour se faire respecter moi je dis
qu'il faut faire la politique du chqu
vide puisque la France pe la deuxième
contribution à l'Union européenne les
pays qui souvent sont concurrentiels de
manière déloyale sont desloyaux pardon
reçoivent de l'argent notamment les pays
de l'Est donc la France vait
conditionner le versement de sa
contribution au respect des règles c'est
quand même la moindre des choses un
dernier mot sur l'Ukraine parce qu'on a
beaucoup importé de produits Ukrainiens
ces derniers mois pour soutenir les
Ukrainiens face à la guerre notamment
des poulets est-ce qu'il faut cesser ses
importations oui on on a trompé les gens
on avait dit aux Ukrainiens les un
certain nombre de produits qui ne
respectent pas en réalité les normes
européennes pourront transiter à travers
l'Europe pour être exporté vers
notamment l'Afrique du Nord où les pays
ont des difficultés d'approvisionnement
pour contourner évidemment l'agression
et la guerre injuste qui mené la Russie
et le blocus de la mer Noire donc on
avait autorisé ces pays ces produits à
traverser l'Europe pour être réexportés
et au lieu d'être réexportés comme il
était prévu ils sont consommés en Europe
ça fait de graves problèmes notamment en
Pologne donc il faut appliquer ce qu'on
avait promis c'est-à-dire les produits
peuvent transiter à travers l'Europe
pour ne pas provoquer de famine
évidemment et de tension sur le marché
mondial mais ils ne doivent pas être
consommés quand ils respectent pas les
normes européennes ça prouve aussi
excusez-moi l'incohérence de vouloir
élargir le marché commun et l'Union
européenne à l'Ukraine on voit bien que
la concurrence ukrainienne
serait très déloyal pour nos produits
que ça nous coûterait une fortune et que
l'Union européenne déjà on a du mal à
comment dire à harmoniser c'est Mo qu'on
puisse dire puisquil y a aucune
harmonisation entre les pays de l'Ouest
et de l'Est si on fait rentrer l'Ukraine
ces 40 millions d'habitants et son
marché agricole ça ruinera l'Union
européenne juste un mot sur le Green
Deal Jordan Bardella appelle à sortir à
laisser tomber le Green Deal à arrêter
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
réussir une transition écologique si si
on abandonne toute toute ambition au
niveau du pacte vert européen B il faut
total changer en fait ce qu'on conçoit
comme une transition écologique
aujourd'hui la transition écologique que
tout le monde souhaite c'est la
décroissance hein la stratégie farm tour
for de la ferme à la fourchette c'est
entre 10 et 15 % de de décroissance
agricole c'est que vous souhaitez la
décroissance non pas du tout justement
ça c'est le modèle européen qu'on veut
nous imposer il faut arrêter avec cela
il faut un autre modèle fondé justement
sur la confiance dans nos agriculteurs
l'agronomie la recherche comment on on
produit mieux avec moins de pesticides
comment on produit mieux avec des
nouvelles semences et c'est là ou ou ce
qu'on appelle les écologistes mais pour
moi ils sont mal nommés ils ils volent
en fait une juste cause sont contre le
progrès je vous rappelle que les le
soulèvement de la terre avait attaqué
des serres près de Nantes euh l'ouest-
France l' suffisamment suivi pour des
salades qui visaient à consommer moins
d'au et de la même manière ils sont
contre un certain nombre de semence ou
de progrès dans la génétique he ils font
peur à tout le monde en disant c'est des
OGM comme les gens n'en voulaient pas
dans les années 90 ce c'est pas ça c'est
d'autres méthodes de recherche et et et
le problème c'est que ce genre
d'écologiste en fait bloque tout progrès
et il prend une mauvaise voie et de la
même manière que les écologistes ont
fait des graves erreurs dans l'énergie
en faisant croire aux Français qu'il y
auraiit toujours suffisamment d'énergie
et qu'on pouvait abîmer le nucléaire et
puis un jour un hiver on s'est retrouvé
sans énergie et bien là ils font la même
erreur avec l'alimentation c'est de
faire croire aux Français et aux
Français qu'il y aura toujours de
l'alimentation pour tout le monde et
bien non dans un monde à 9 milliards
d'habitants euh produire assez
d'alimentation de qualité et saine c'est
un enjeu très important et je n'aimerait
pas qu'on se retrouve un jour notamment
par exemple sans lait parce qu'on a euh
euh saccagé l'levage français quand les
écologistes appellent à soutenir les
agriculteurs vous vous y croyez
moyennement c'est eux qui n'y croient
pas enfin sincèrement l'accueil le
retour des des paysans mobilisés sur le
terrain contre le soutien des
écologistes il est très dur très violent
parfois même trop violent et ça il faut
jamais s'attaquer aux personnes
évidemment voilà donc les écologistes
aujourd'hui qui sont une fois plus très
mal nommés sont des décroissants hier
l'issue du conseil des ministres pris
catev a parlé de de ceux qui ont
découvert l'existence des agriculteurs
la semaine dernière qui se sont rués sur
les agriculteurs pour satisfaire leur
manè électoral et qui les oublieront
aussitôt vous êtes sentivisé pas du tout
une fois plus prescat tevenau elle
aurait dû écouter ce qu'on lui disait
quand on disait que le GNR la taxation
du GNR serait la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase on a déposé pas moins
en un an de six questions au
gouvernement pour l'alerter sur le
mouvement du retournement des plaques à
l'entrée de nos communes rurales je l'ai
aussi je vous rappelle que c'est prise
catous parce qu'elle avait pris la
parole à l'époque elle était député qui
avait refusé ma proposition de
sanctionner les associations violentes
qui pénétent
par exemple à Saint Soline pour saccager
le système hydrique et l'irrigation des
agriculteurs ou qui ou qui attaqué les
seres voulais leur supprimer leur
avantage fiscal B ben c'est des
personnes comme Madame tevnoau qu'on
refusé de le faire donc s'il y a bien
une personne qui a découvert
l'agriculture c'est Madame tevnoau et de
toute évidence aussi monsieur hatal qui
a l'air de découvrir les bottes de foin
alors Gabriel hatal justement qui est en
tête du palmarès de l'adhésion c'est un
baromètre mensuel au doxa pour Public
Sénat et la presse régionale et c'est la
personnalité politique préférée devant
Jordan Bardella devant Marine Le Pen il
est une menace pour vousos européenne
écoutez c'est les Français décideront
moi je pense que Maron monsieur hatal va
s'épuiser d'ailleurs ça a déjà commencé
dans une tâche impossible que a donné
monsieur Macron c'est-à-dire vouloir
changer de politique sans lui laisser
aucune autonomie politique et on a bien
vu monsieur Macron à peine monsieur
hatal été nommé qui fait un discours de
politique générale à sa place très
humiliant d'ailleurs pour lui et aussi
pas respectueux dans institution et
Monsieur le Maire on n' jamais vu ça qui
prend les devants sur son premier
ministre pour aller annoncer la hausse
des factures d'électricité de 10 % enfin
il y avait dit 9,8 % pasteint 10 % je
pense que là on est à un niveau quand
même maximal pour se moquer
malheureusement des Français et donc
monsieur hatal on le voit bien avec les
agriculteurs moi j'étais très attentif à
ce qu'il a dit et en fait il fait des
constats il critique 7 ans de macronisme
il reprend les mots du du rassemblement
national mais il va pas appliquer les
mesures et donc les Français se rendront
compte que même si monsieur hatal est
sympathique il n'a aucune liberté
politique et il appliquera la même
politique que Monsieur Macron depuis 7
ans une dernière question Stéphan
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de son
discours de politique générale cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée il peut faire
des annonces supplémentaires bah
peut-être qu'il va nous surprendre mais
moi compte tenu de ce qu'a fait monsieur
Macron ou Monsieur le Maire je ne vois
pas ce qui lui reste comme annonce je
n'ai pas compris pourquoi il a voulu
prendre autant de temps pour ce discours
de politique générale ça lui a
complètement coupé l'herbe sous le pied
et je vois pas trop ce qui lui reste
dans le moteur bah écoutez on va voir ce
qu'annonce monsieur Atal mais je suis
assez dubitatif je rappelle aussi ce qui
a été pe dit pour le moment que la
mission principale de Monsieur Atal
c'est un plan d'austérité de 12
milliards d'euros donc j'attends de voir
les coupes et c'est à une de Bo fr
justement discours à l'Assemblée que va
dire gabrielleal c'est la question ce
matin la Une de votre journal merci
Stéphane merci jeanph d'avoir été avec
nous on continue avec le club des
territoire